dès 9 ans ce sont déjà des petits génies
d'internet
là on est en train de de présenter un
peu comme le team deux jours de fête et
moi ils me demandent par exemple
réalisateur le genre la durée les
costumes et les questions d'heures ou là
les armes et les a trouvés assez
facilement la sa demande ça demande un
peu plus de travail dans cherche
aujourd'hui par petits groupes ces
élèves doivent résoudre des énigmes pour
le défi web une activité pédagogique qui
demandent de la curiosité mais pas
seulement
les élèves ont collaboré ensemble pour
réussir un objectif commun chacun va
rechercher des réponses sur internet va
essayer d'apporter sa petite patte pour
que l'ensemble de la classe puisse avoir
l'activité réussi défi web mais aussi
journal de classe en ligne exposé à
construire cette salle de classe de
cm1-cm2 apprend à se servir de nouvelles
technologies dès que l'occasion se
présente
cette génération qui a mené avec celle
qu'il a généralement une information sur
un site internet pour eux c'est vrai
donc comment faire pour qu'ils aient un
esprit cloutier qui se méfier ou rebondi
à chaque fois qu'il ya une information
qui nous parlera et rené comment tu en
est arrivé à cette information là
comment on peut éviter de trouver une
erreur au recoupement de l'information
en faisant confiance à certains sites
plus qu'à d'autres
et petit à petit leur construire voilà
un bagage qui leur permettent
pas de naviguer le mieux possible éviter
certains maux de la société actuelle et
faire grandir en toute transparence faut
se méfier de certaines choses sur
internet
c'est dangereux en classe on apprend à
savoir sur les bons sites vous faut
aller sur les sons les exposés en
s'expérimente en poussant on peut savoir
si c'est bien que c'est pas bien seront
ce qu'on a dit l'éducation nationale se
modernise et s'adapte à son époque